you do it you ping-pong hey doll the one
that yeah unless it's funny it can be
funny it's just between yourself yeah
Patrice was it was one of the best one
of the best funny haters okay okay you
you bring up a good point comedic hate
conahey yeah comedic ate one of the not
one of the probably the best Patrice
Patrice I don't know what I would talk
and if I was saying something you just
hear what would you tell buddies what
what do you talk about you like just the
way you talk but what your voice
everything about your voice just makes
me want to punch you in the face
wait talking about when he would go
after you two it kind of made you feel
good to like if you're a commis
especially if your comic like I called
Opie and Anthony once I was talking them
and Anthony anything he always has a gun
on him Harry's a gun everywhere like he
has a concealed carry permit and shit
and I said to him I said do you ever
worry that maybe you're putting out this
energy and you're manifesting something
like some sort of an attack on you
because you're constantly dwelling on it
you always have this gun and Patrice
goes don't believe in magic don't
believe me conjuring up the world
he's magic he would go after you man
it's like you just want to step back and
watch I don't know but he got bill burr
so man long time our bill used to get so
fucking mad beautiful thing about bill
barber we'd be snapping bill bill is the
guy that's not funny
funny you build like where's the punch
line in it there's no punch line he was
just so fucking mad we the Comedy Cellar
the days that we had there man bill burr
Patrice O'Neal Keith Robinson Jim Norton
Colin Quinn myself when I say we would
sit at this table we would sit at this
table for four to five hours and it
would be nothing but beautiful trash uns
so one another when I say they used to
give me so much shit that's probably why
it's so hard to bother me now the trash
ins that I took from the age 20 to 24
and my young comedic career about how
awful I was I had a joke I had a joke
where to be get into my career cuz of
the times let me preface this this was
way in the beginning of my career this
was a joke that I had about about little
people midgets at the time and you know
it was so bad soon as I got robbed by
cross-eyed Mitch and the joke was I
didn't know he was robbing me because I
was with somebody else so he was looking
at my friend but he was robbing me it
was like a play on being cross very very
awful joke I remember telling his joke
in a phone book comes flying on the
stage could trees through a fucking
phone book at me I'm talking this is
where the Boston comedy club people in a
crowd tiny little place all you heard
was and you sit back it hits the floor I
say what the fuck was that and Patrice
said read it it's better material in it
than what you're saying that cross stars
laughs he's uh
they all got safe they used to trash me
so bad so bad man get your legendary
tree some news story a corporate trees
jerking off at my house before this is I
moved to LA understanding the
two-bedroom apartment I just got there
protrudes coming out I said yo you need
place ass I got two bedrooms
you can come near my ex-wife at the time
you know I come home say
afternoon like Patrice am i yo you all
Patrice Patrice I go on the bag open up
the door I said his big-ass computer
Paul all I see is his back hunched over
so baby oil right and I come in on my oh
joy that you'll get out get out get out
[Laughter]
he's so sick he's so sick that he didn't
stop he was so concerned with finishing
then he didn't even break stride he
didn't turn around it's not really
nothing he get out get out you just saw
his back hunched he came out like seven
minutes later was like my bad i may use
come home fucking Patrice man I love him
to death love him to death
yeah he had the most don't give a fuck
of any time I ever met I think it was
most 100% yeah good am bad yeah you know
there was there was a good to it and
there was also some bad you know a lot
of things that didn't have been for
Patrice probably could have happened but
I think the the level of not give a fuck
yeah prevented some of those things well
he was almost too authentic yes
like his did you ever see that was it
Charlie Sheen's roast whose roast was it
that he did what he just torch everybody
else's on the roasting them and then he
got up there and have the fuckers on on
my level be here with you guys oh who
the fuck is this bit who is this bitch
oh my god Patrice has so many of those
things yeah so many of things one of one
of the best to do it if you if you are
listening you're not educated I'm
Patrice O'Neal just I
as did you just watch elven room one of
his special yeah some of that some of
the funniest should have a man and so
insightful
mmm-hmm he was so wide the way people
thought and behaved he would say shit
like one of the things that he said that
I tell people all the time it's oh it's
a brilliant thing that he said it was I
forget what controversy it was but he
was on television with some woman who
was saying that you should never tell
jokes about certain things you know and
they were they were getting mad at
someone I think it was Opie and Anthony
about a joke and he said you gotta
understand that all jokes come from the
same place the ones you like and the
ones you don't like the ones that make
you laugh and the ones that make you mad
they all come from the same place
someone's just trying to be funny
yeah like sometimes they just don't work
I had a talk I had a talk with the I
forgot her name I got I forgot her name
but it was when I was doing all the
promo for upside and they kept trying to
break down you know where where where
the jokes come from you know Kevin these
insensitive jokes scene that you told
back then why what makes you why would
you even say those things and the
hardest thing for me to explain I was
like do you think people think of jokes
and while thinking of them think that
they're not going to be funny everything
that you think of in a joke form you're
thinking of it because you think you're
gonna get a laugh behind it
yeah the gamble is if I get the laugh
versus not get the laugh don't get to
laugh the joke was not funny if I get a
laugh then I guess I'm on to something
there isn't a bunch of thought that goes
into the funny moments that we think may
be great bits yeah I wish that I had a
more logical answer to put behind it I
said but I don't especially at that time
my career I just thought it would be
funny the same way that some people
think sir jokes funny the offer it's a
thought comedians are constantly
throwing shit out there yeah you're
constantly rolling a dice and Thor shit
out there have to shit you roll and good
right it's not gonna be good the other
hand maybe alright maybe kind of good
but it's all
with the intent of entertaining it's not
with the intent of being malicious is
not with the intent of sparking hatred
it's all trying to make you laugh yeah
that's it like it's it's literally that
simple
from a thought within a comedians mind
yeah nothing nothing else and they kept
trying to look for this like hard
definition of why and that's like I
don't have it I don't have the reason
why I thought it would be funny and it
wasn't that's the downfall